Hello everybody!
Sorry I'm late guys.
Sorry, I got stuck in a Mario Party collab.
It got started late.
It got started late because they were trying to find one last person.
So I was just zoning out.
And then, I swear, it said two turns.
But that two turns had to be the longest fucking two turns of my life.
Like, everybody was thinking.
And so I was like, what is there to think?
There's only two turns left.
What is there to think?
Just...
Just go!
I was literally the last.
I rolled the lowest die, so I was the last person.
I had the last turn.
So I had to wait 20 hours until it was my turn.
And I'm just like, what is there to think?
We all know who's gonna lose anyway.
I got...
Two turns at the end was so rough.
Did we win?
We all won.
Except for one person.
That's how it should have been.
As it should be.
Okay, give me a sec.
I need to make sure my Silent Hill is...
Okay, I need to make sure the audio for Silent Hill is correct.
Before we begin.
God, I'm not looking forward to it.
Oh my god.
I think this game has to be one of the scariest games I've ever played in my life.
Definitely, I'm not looking forward to it.
I think Silent Hill is the scariest.
I don't think I've ever...
Okay, other than Visage.
Visage is very scary.
But I think...
The Silent Hill 2 has been very freaking freaky for me.
I think also because...
I think it's also because...
The fact that...
The monsters come back to life.
I don't like that.
I don't like the fact that the monsters come back to life.
They don't stay dead.
So I feel like I'm always...
I feel like I'm wasting materials.
Trying to kill them.
But I can't do anything else.
I can't do anything else.
That's the only thing I can do.
But yeah.
But anyway, so...
I am not looking forward...
It's actually so scary.
I hate that.
I hate that part of the game.
Life update.
What do I have for life update?
Let me see.
I always write down life updates that I want to give...
Let you guys know.
Anything...
Any interesting life updates that I have.
Stuff is being shipped out.
Starting today.
Bundles will be shipped out very soon.
But a lot of items...
For solo items have started to ship out starting today.
Did I tell you guys?
Wait, did I tell you guys about the distributor thing?
It's solved now.
So...
Did I tell you?
I didn't even know if I updated you guys this.
Basically, me and the older distributor were able to establish contact again.
And we fixed the scenario about it.
So, the ex-director has nothing involved anymore.
Cannot do anything to the distributor anymore.
So, me and the old distributor was able to finally communicate.
And they're not holding my merch hostage anymore.
So, they started shipping stuff out starting today.
So, I'm happy about that.
So, thank fucking god.
That's one headache.
I don't have to worry about now.
So, bundles will be shipped out soon, TM.
Because we need a restock.
Because our ex-director did hold some merchandise hostage.
So, we don't have everything for the bundles.
Because we're missing some stuff for bundles.
So, we have to order restock.
But the distributor does have a lot of the things that we can ship out now.
So, thank fucking god.
Sadly, we won't be working with this old distributor.
Because we actually made a deal with a new distributor.
And we're running a test run with the new distributor.
For the Doki Bird acrylic stand.
Let me show you guys what it looks like.
It looks really...
We're just waiting on it to be shipped over right now to our new distributor.
Because we were trying to figure out what the fuck to do at that point.
And we're like, alright, let's do a test run with this other distributor.
And oh my god.
So, you know how we have the acrylic stand?
So, this is what it looks like.
This is what it's gonna look like.
It looks really good.
I'm really happy with it.
Let me grab the image.
Oh my god.
It's a giant ass image.
Let me resize this.
Also, I'm stalling.
I'm 100% stalling right now.
But yes!
This is what it looks like.
I know it looks different from what you bought.
But I wanted to thank you guys for waiting for so long.
This is what the acrylic stand looks like on the shop.
So, yeah.
This is what it's gonna look like.
This is gonna be with our new distributor.
And we're doing a test run with this.
And the moment we finally get all the merch stuff situated, I can take less sponsors.
Because that's the only...
I have to take sponsors because it's good supplement to income and the stuff I want to do.
Because I don't have the merch supplement right now.
So, the moment everything is fixed regarding distribution, I can finally do merchandise again.
And then I can take less sponsors.
Which is great.
Because less sponsors means more time for me to do more stuff that I want to do creative-wise.
Because then I don't have to worry about income.
I don't have to worry about income-wise and stuff.
Because I need income to...
I need extra income for the ideas I want to do and everything.
So, I'm very excited working with this new distributor to see how that goes.
But, yeah.
I have so many ideas regarding merchandise I can finally do.
After this test run, if everything goes well with the test run, there's a lot of stuff I really, really want to do.
I wrote down some stuff that I want to do.
But...
It's not like sponsors don't give a lot of money.
They do.
But like...
Merchandising...
I think you guys know this.
But if I was able to focus on merchandising, it could make up at least 70% of my income.
But obviously, I can't.
Because I want to make sure you guys are getting the products that you ordered before.
And everything is situated.
So, the moment it's all fixed, I don't have to worry too much about sponsors and stuff.
And I can be a little bit more picky regarding what I want to do for sponsors.
Merchandising does a lot.
It does so much.
That's why a lot of companies end up becoming merch companies.
It doesn't matter how well a show does or a video game does.
If it's not merchandisable, That's why you see a lot of good shows and a lot of good games get cancelled.
Or they don't get a sequel or anything.
Because they're like, we can't make merch off of it.
There's no reason.
There's no reason to.
Because we can't make merch off of it.
That's why merchandising is so fucking important.
Because it does make up a lot of the income for people.
We finally fixed the distributor issue.
So, I'm really happy.
I sent photos of things being packaged today.
So, that was super exciting.
Also, I found out the WrestleTuber belts are starting to arrive.
People are starting to receive the stuff from WrestleTuber.
Which is great.
I actually never got a chance to...
Because I was so busy.
I never asked for a photo of what the belt actually looks like in person.
Other than the graphics I provided.
I actually never got a chance to see what the physical item looks like.
But I saw BuffPuff and Meriwether recently received their belts.
And this is what it looks like.
It looks so cool.
It looks amazing.
It actually looks amazing.
Basically...
The people who won the show matches and the tournament winners get their belt.
And...
Oh my god.
It looks fucking amazing.
So, huge shoutout for Gamersubs for basically sponsoring the creation of the belts.
They basically paid for the belts and stuff for everybody.
But yeah.
I'm really happy with how that turned out.
So, I think that is all the life updates.
Let me see if there's any other life updates I have.
I love stalling when I...
Thank god for stalling.
Let's go.
Wings, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Please, for the love of god, make a croaky plushie that when you hug it has that laugh from when you first showed up as croaky.
Thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Well...
That's all I'll say.
Sooner than you think.
Good!
Thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
In one stream today, Beto just passed you in this game.
Make sure he gets his belt.
Thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Wait, did he just started playing today?
Like, bro, this game is freaky, man.
This game... Oh my god, this game is really scary, guys.
I don't know, guys.
This game is so scary.
I've never, like...
Every other game, I've never wanted to stall as much as this game.
Because it actually...
Oh my god, like...
There's just something about this game that's just really...
It, like, fucks me up.
It actually... Oh my god.
It, like, actually is one of the scariest games I've ever played.
Because the gun does nothing.
The gun does fucking nothing!
They
come back to life.
What's the point?
They come back to life.
Thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
And thank you for helping me stall longer.
Doki, could you really be in this town?
Pasta, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
I know it's scary, Doki.
It is for me, too.
And I played and beat the OG many times.
But you and your streams are bright lights in a dark time right now.
Thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Okay, I'm ready.
Oh my god, I'm not.
Disclaimer, I'm not actually ready.
I'm not ready.
But I'm ready.
But I'm not.
Guys, I hope tomorrow we get knocked out in the first game.
It's, like, best of... I don't remember.
It's, like, knockout stage.
So you lose the matches, you're out of the game.
So I hope tomorrow we get knocked out instantly.
So then I don't have to... we only stream for, like, an hour.
And then we rest until 9pm.
By the way, tomorrow's tournament for Shinova.
We're not sponsored by it, by the way.
Superchat, just so you can stall...
Oh, thanks, Alan!
Thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Django, thank you for the superchat.
Stalling funds.
Oh my god, you guys shouldn't have.
Thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh my god, guys.
I'm gonna open up Streamlabs.
I just realized it's been so long since I've looked at my Streamlabs, guys.
I might as well, you know, for everybody here, I might as well open my Streamlabs, guys.
Just so... just cause, like, I must have missed so many Streamlabs donations.
Oh my god, I gotta catch up.
Did you guys donate on Streamlabs?
Oh my god, let me check.
Let me make sure, guys, that I read all of your donations.
And make sure that, like, you are all represented in my superchat reading.
Oh my god, Kilzerk, thank you for the donation!
On the 15th!
You, yeah, you, the person who might read this.
I hope you're resting well.
Wow, thank you, Kilzerk.
I really appreciate that.
Anyway, Wings, thank you for the super... oh wait, sorry.
D-Dragon, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Um, Scared Game, you ever played?
Doki, please, play the OG and see which is it.
No, because you're behind due to... by the way, you're behind due to all of this stalling.
Thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Snooks, thank you for the superchat.
It's a more comedy from the side of the screen.
Good luck, Doki.
We enjoy Scaredy Bird.
Thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Wings, thank you for the superchat.
Doki, it's okay.
I want you to take comfort in the fact that if we were in a haunted house that any dragon you were with would make you go first.
That's fucked up.
That is so fucked up.
Thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Speaking of haunted houses, next week I'm gonna go to... I'm actually gonna go touch grass next week.
Because next week, I managed to convince a friend to go with me to a haunted house.
I know, I know it's crazy.
I know, I can't believe it.
Willingly, I consented to it too.
I actually consented to it.
And I convinced a friend to come with me to travel to me just to...
To travel to my city to go to a haunted house.
I was like, are you busy next week?
And they were like, no, I don't think so.
I was like, come over to a haunted house.
Travel all the way here to a haunted house.
Hahaha
Airborne Ninja, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
If the gun did something, would it be as scary?
Also, just hit them with a stick.
James is a...
But they come back to life!
They actually come back to life.
That's so fucked up.
That's the worst part.
Ninja, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Mic donation, reading time.
You know what the fact that this works is because the really fucked up part is that this works because like we haven't had a super chat reading time in a long time, so like, it's always been like a gotcha if I see your super chat in time to read it in time,
so like, thank you for enabling me.
We're stalling, but you guys, the real problem is you guys for enabling this.
Uh,
Mike, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Donation reading time.
Gladstone, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Funds to ensure you stop stalling.
Uh, Neppers, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Stalling can also refer to aircraft and engines.
Uh, SleepyAsh, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Your stream is helping me stall this essay due, and okay, wait, I'm not here to be a bad example here.
Wait, guys, I, guys, we all, guys, all I'm saying is that, uh, all I'm saying is that, look, I know like, we were, I was giving the wrong message in my sponsored stream this morning, but guys, I, you watched me to realize what you shouldn't be doing.
Guys, I show you guys what a bad person is, like, I'm here to show you guys, like, what happens, um, if you're destined to go to hell.
Uh, SleepyAsh, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Oh, wait, I already read that.
Influx, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Um, hey, Doki, say you didn't want to play the Yakuza games because they took, uh, your dad's too long to beat.
If that's a problem, you should check out, like, a dragon.
It's a super, okay, I'm pretty sure that's also, like, really fucking long.
Thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
How long to beat?
Oh, shit, it's, like, 12 hours.
Wouldn't I need to know, like, the story, though, for, like, a dragon?
I heard they were making a pirate game, too.
Um, I heard they're making a, uh, a pirate game in the future of Yakuza.
Guys, this, okay, I shouldn't keep stalling.
I...
But I read there was a birthday supa, so we have one more stall.
And thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Hi, Doki, first supa and first stall supa.
It's also my birthday!
Can I request a little... Of course!
Happy birthday to you, happy birthday to you, happy birthday, dear Anne, happy birthday to you.
Yay!
Alright.
I'm ready.
Oh, I'm fucking ready.
Okay.
Here we go.
Oh, my God.
Alright, this is it.
Kielcer, thank you for the aka supa!
Thank you, thank you!
Thank you, Kielcer!
That really means so much!
Thank you!
Oh, my God, where am I?
Oh, I remember where I am now.
I remember.
Okay, I still remember.
What do I do?
Wait, what do I do?
Oh, no, I don't remember.
Do I have anything in my inventory?
What do I have?
Guys, what...
I don't remember.
I actually don't remember.
Where do I go?
Yeah, I did.
I put the hour hand in.
But, like, where do I go after?
Guys, this is not stalling.
I'm actually confused.
Where do I go?
Check the clock?
Well, that's the... Is this the hour hand?
Oh, I got the hour hand.
So I should go to the left.
Oh, no, it's this way.
Oh, there you go.
Oh, that's freaky.
I don't like that.
That's... Oh, I don't like that sound.
Oh, I don't know.
I'm really... I'm really sad.
I'm really sad.
Okay.
Alright.
It's time to go forward.
Guys, how do I heal again?
Guys, what's the button to heal, guys?
Customize, control, dodge, reload.
Where the fuck is the heal?
Where is the heal?
Okay.
V, okay.
Alright.
I don't remember how to play this game already.
I don't remember.
Hello, women.
The life of the party is here.
Hello, ladies.
Ladies.
Oh, hey.
Okay, alright.
Okay.
Here we go.
I'm not ready.
What's in this bathroom?
Oh, my God.
Hello.
Oh.
Stick your hand in the toilet.
What could go wrong?
Let's go.
What can go wrong?
I'm just gonna lose an entire arm.
No way.
This is just all in my mind.
It's all in my mind.
What?
Okay.
This is not real.
It's all in your mind, James.
None of this is real.
None of this is real, James.
None of it is real.
You just... You have to stop taking your meds, James.
You know what they say.
If you stop taking your meds, your dead wife won't be dead no more.
You can still hear her.
Oh, no.
It's a puzzle within a fucking puzzle.
Like, what more do you want from me?
Oh, hey.
Hey, there.
Wait, is this the one that spits?
I can't remember.
It is.
Oh, it is.
Yeah, that's the spitty one.
Oh, my God.
This is why I don't play this.
This is why I don't play this one more than once a week.
I do not play this one more than once.
Oh, my God.
What the fuck?
Why is there a puzzle within a goddamn puzzle?
Are you not... Do you not have enough?
Do you not have enough of me?
I'm trying to fucking figure out what to do in life.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
Reload.
Alright.
Do I go left or right?
I guess right.
But, like, what if there's something funny on the left side?
Could be something silly.
Silly.
Where am I?
I didn't expect actually something silly here.
Anything silly?
Hello?
Wait.
I didn't mean it.
I don't... I don't... I don't want the silly.
I was joking.
Please.
Keep it the same.
I don't want the silly no more.
No.
No, I wasn't.
Guys, I wasn't.
I would never give you ASMR for free.
You know that.
Guys, I would never do that.
What?
Hello?
Is that a bee?
Is that... Oh, what is that?
My God.
What the fuck?
The fuck is this?
Figurine part?
The fuck is that?
I don't know what that was.
What the fuck?
Oh, this is a normal guy.
I know... I know you don't spit.
I know you don't spit.
Get out!
You don't spit.
You swa...
I'm sorry.
What about paid stalling ASMR?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay, alright.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Have you ever been... Wait, I am Canadian.
What do you mean?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I knew... No!
I'm predictable now!
You can make an AI of the things I'd say now.
No!
I can't... Technically, I feel like you can actually make an AI of the, like, Doki Bird sayings.
Alright.
You guys know me too well.
I actually want to try that.
Like, I saw like some VTubers made like a... Like, you know, fun AI.
There's like bad AI, but then there's also fun AI.
And one of the fun AIs is literally just like... Also like... Am I lagging a little bit?
I can't tell.
Maybe it's because I have 200 things running in the background.
Let me... Guys, do you think that's a possibility?
Let me close some tabs real quick.
Alright.
Let me close some stuff real quick.
Oh yeah, I know 100%.
I have a lot of tabs open.
Let me close some tabs real quick.
Okay, wait.
I need to keep... Not this one.
This tab is very important.
Oh, this tab is also very important.
Guys, don't worry.
I'm getting there.
Okay, and then I'll delete these.
And...
And then I'll delete this.
Okay, I should be a little better now, right?
Not for free?
Okay.
Thank you for the Akasupa, Ninja.
Thank you, thank you.
Wait, how did your super make me lag even more?
How does that...
Thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you, thank you.
I think also I didn't restart my... Okay, let me put the frames...
Let's not put it in limited.
Oh, 60?
Really?
Nah, we'll be fine.
We'll be fine.
There we go.
Okay, the weight of that super.
What the fuck did I do with this?
Let me know if I'm still lagging a little.
Okay, can I bash this?
No.
Oh, I can.
I feel me, I'm good.
There we go.
What the fuck is this?
Oh, 2-1-1.
Okay.
I don't know.
I don't feel safe in here.
Okay.
Oh my god, alright.
Let me go grab some stuff.
Just give me ammo!
Like, give me some heals!
For anyone who talks Adoki and play the Silent Hill radio... No, that's fucked up, bro.
That is so fucked up.
What have I ever... Oh my god, look at... Ooh.
See those cheeks?
Let's shoot her right there.
Is she gonna do one at me?
Got you!
I saw it.
I didn't see that, though.
God damn it.
Wait, was she just there?
Oh my god, I got baited.
I actually got fucking baited.
Okay, because for that Aka... Hey boy, what you doing?
Hey there.
You see those cheeks?
Pew pew!
Okay, um...
Alright, I ate some medication.
Oh, hey.
Oh, thank fucking god.
That's what I needed.
That's actually what I needed there.
Did I do the puzzle correctly?
Alright.
I guess it's puzzle time.
I swear to god.
Be gone.
Be gone!
I might not have taken my meds!
Be gone, wench!
Alright, let's do the puzzle.
Um...
Oh.
Oh, I have to combine them.
Okay, give me a sec.
Um, it'll be very awkward if he comes back to life while I'm trying to combine shit.
Okay, there we go.
God, that looks so ugly.
Like, what happened to it?
Alright.
Okay.
I guess I'll put him here.
I guess I'll put... What kind of puzzle is this?!
It's trial and error!
This is not a natural puzzle!
It's literally trial and error!
Okay.
Alright, back into the keyhole.
The key goes into the keyhole.
Oh, don't tell me to go... God fucking... Okay.
Go downstairs time.
Downstairs time.
Down I go.
Alright.
Hello?
What am I looking at?
It's a broken table.
We've seen so many broken things already.
What's... Oh no, there's...
That's a lot of places I haven't been to.
Oh no.
That's a lot of areas I haven't been to.
Are you fucking serious?
Oh, thank God.
More ammo.
That's fine.
Oh, and more heals.
That's also fine.
Okay.
Thank you for not softlocking me.
I really appreciate it.
Because I don't know what I'll do if I get softlocked.
I'll actually cry.
Please don't make me cry.
Please.
That's all I ask.
Oh no, I guess I'll go this way.
Hello?
Hey there.
I don't like that the hallway is so dark over there.
I mean, at least somebody's paying the electricity bill.
You know?
Because I know I'm like walking.
And I could be not walking.
But you don't understand, guys.
I have a lot of fears right now.
And walking is the only way that can help me.
Oh hey, at least somebody's doing graffiti.
Pyramidhead is paying the bills.
We share a bank account!
He's literally... He's not supposed to be paying anything.
Like, I'm literally the one taking care of both of us right now.
He's literally me.
We're sharing a fucking bank account.
Wait, what?
Who's here?
Hello?
Who are you?
Angela?
Is that the girl from the graveyard?
Guys, I feel like it's been 20 years.
I literally forgot about it.
I forgot what she looked like.
I forgot what this fucking girl looked like.
It's been so long.
I feel like I've been in Silent Hill for like 5 years now.
Her?
Me?
Wait, that knife is bloody.
Who did you stab?
I'm sorry.
What the fuck is going on?
Is she also part of my imagination?
Yet?
How did you get here?
I just figured because this is where you're looking for her.
How else would I know?
Yeah.
Like, why are you here?
Why else would you be here?
Is she okay?
What does she see in Silent Hill?
Because every time, each person sees Silent Hill differently.
Also, I wonder what she sees.
No one is okay in this game.
I'm okay!
James seems like a very perfectly well-adjusted human being.
Who just happens to not take his meds.
Because he's all better now, guys.
I don't know either.
Okay.
I'm not crazy.
I'm just trying to find my very much alive dead wife.
Don't.
I'm definitely not crazy.
You have a knife!
Well, how would you slow me down?
You can stab them.
You've clearly done it before.
You've got a fucking knife with blood on it.
Woah!
Lady!
What the fuck did you do, man?
Do you see the hot, sexy monsters too, like me?
By the way, I know this is an inappropriate question to ask, but I'm just curious.
Oh cool, I got a knife.
Angela's knife.
Can I stab her?
Stab people with it?
Not her, sorry.
Sorry, that was a slip of tongue.
I did not mean that I wanna stab her.
It's not a usable weapon?
The fuck is that for then?
Okay, guys.
I drank a lot of water, so I'm gonna hydrate before I go out there.
For my safety.
I'll be right back.
I'm back.
Sorry, I also had to turn on both my lights.
My hallway light and my living room light too.
Because you know why.
I had to make sure I turned on both.
Guys, my morning sponsor is gonna pay my electricity bill.
Don't worry.
The sponsor I did this morning will pay it off.
It'll pay off my entire Silent Hill run.
Guys, no, you don't understand.
It's getting dark.
It's winter now.
It's almost winter.
It's getting dark right now.
You guys don't understand.
It's getting dark.
Oh my god.
Why?
That's all I wanna know.
Why is it like this?
Okay.
Everything is fine.
Okay, I'm okay.
I'm okay.
Did I go here before?
It's here.
Okay, it's there.
Okay.
Be brave.
Oh, I hate.
I hate.
I wanna be back outside.
I don't wanna be inside no more.
I don't wanna be in these goddamn fucking tight corridors.
Okay.
Open.
Hello.
Dude, we're not even in the hospital yet.
That's the worst part.
Doki, how do you know about the hospital?
Because the nurses had to come from somewhere.
I watched Silent Hill.
The movie.
The nurses has to come from somewhere, so I assume it comes from the fucking hospital.
Okay.
I marked that off.
Good job.
Good job, James.
Dr. Cranberry, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Winter is coming.
Our crops have dried up before their expected yield.
It will be a hard winter.
We will starve.
This is how I feel when I play this game.
This is how I feel.
Hello?
Woah.
Woah there.
When I say hello, I didn't mean for you to say hello back.
It was just a figure of expression.
You don't have to say hi back.
In fact, I encourage you not to say hi back.
What's this?
Read.
Ver la flemme.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Paladin Knight, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Here's to free Doki.
You should look at that picture of Mary in your inventory a lot throughout the game.
It will comfort you.
Which picture?
This one?
I mean, that's just my... that's my dead wife.
Right there.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
She does not look very comforting.
I'm just gonna say it.
I do not feel any joy looking at that photo right now.
Like, I guess if I haven't seen women in a long time, I'd be like, whoa, man, my dead wife sure does get me going right now.
But I think that's inappropriate.
I don't know.
Just a little bit.
Might be a bit inappropriate right there.
Oh, what the fuck?
What the fuck?
You can't do that.
Oh, hey.
Nice.
Forever together.
Okay.
Alright.
Gotta reload.
Like, how the fuck did she know I was gonna shoot?
Okay, into this corner I go.
Okay, unlock the door.
Door unlocked.
Where the fuck am I?
Where am I?
Where is this place?
Oh, clock!
Clock, clock, clock.
Right here.
Alright, oh my god, we made it back.
Oh, thank god, we made it back.
We made it back.
Oh my god, I swear, this has to be the slowest Silent Hill run of everybody's lives.
Where is it supposed to go?
Here we go.
Alright, now we go to the M.
Oh my god.
Now we go to M.
You can brute force?
Yeah, but I'm...
What do you take me for?
I'm smarter than you think, guys.
I think.
Okay.
Alright, this way.
Alright.
Are there bosses in Silent Hill?
There has to be.
Like, I gotta fight Pyramid Head one day, right?
Like, I've just been fighting little babies.
There has to be a boss in Silent Hill.
M, M, M, M, M.
Oh, someone's a masochist.
Hello.
Oh.
Oh, M for Moth.
Can't be that dangerous.
Oh, that's a little...
A little peephole right there.
Oh, okay.
Let me destroy this first before anything.
Alright.
M for Morphosis, you're right.
Okay, there's the death... there's the...
Oh, wait.
There's another Moth.
Wait, what am I supposed to do?
Oh, is this a puzzle?
Oh, no.
Oh, there's another one.
It's right here.
And then there's... what am I supposed to do with all these Moths?
Oh, wait.
It is a puzzle.
Okay.
Alright.
There's that.
There's the tiger.
There's the orange Moth.
What is this puzzle?
M minus...
There's numbers?
What do the numbers mean?
There's...
It doesn't even tell me what the numbers mean.
Like, it doesn't even tell me what number is what.
Like, how the fuck am I supposed to know what Moth equals what number?
Where's that intel?
Swear to God, when I get here, I better get me some fucking intel.
Okay.
I move.
One tiger Moth.
Two dead Moths.
Okay.
Is that how many Moths are in this room?
Alright, guys.
Sesame Street time.
One, two... there's two of that Moths.
One...
Two...
Three...
Three Owl Moths.
And then...
Two of the other Moths.
Okay, three Owl Moths.
Okay, the fuck is the moon?
Oh, that one.
Okay.
One...
Minus...
Wait, what?
There was only one.
There's two.
Okay, two...
Two Night Moths.
Minus...
Zero.
No.
Negative one.
The fuck?
Oh, I missed.
Oh, shit.
Zero.
Okay, zero.
Zero...
And then we had...
Two Tiger Moths.
Okay.
Two Death Moths.
Plus three...
So that's...
Five...
Zero, five...
One.
Zero, five, one.
Okay, zero...
Wait, there's no zero.
Guys...
I think I'm gonna fail Sesame Street.
One...
Two...
I thought there was three.
Is there not three?
Yeah, three!
There's three of that.
Three of that, so...
Three minus...
Owl...
One...
Two...
Three!
That's zero!
Is there not a z-
I swear to god, the moon's facing the wrong way.
See?
One...
Two...
Three.
Is it the amount of wings?
Oh my god, okay.
One...
Two...
Oh my god, it's the amount of wings.
I...
There's no way.
Cause that's four.
And then...
There's...
The symbols.
Is it the amount of symbols?
One, two...
Three...
Oh my god, it's the symbols!
Three, four...
But then that's five!
One, two...
Three, four, five...
That's five!
One, two...
Oh my god, it's one, two, three, four...
Four...
Five, six...
Seven, eight...
So eight minus five...
Three, that's three.
Okay, there's three.
Oh my god, this is...
This is dumb.
I'm gonna put it here.
Okay, three, okay...
Oh my god, how many was...
Was the fucking eyes again?
One, two...
Three...
Four, five...
Okay, five...
Six, seven...
Okay, seven...
That's seven.
And then...
Oh my god...
I already forgot how much was that again.
Five!
Okay, five minus two...
Then it's three.
That was...
Oh my god, that was so dumb.
I thought it was the amount of moffs.
That was so stupid.
I went with the amount of moffs, not the amount of symbols.
Alright, stick your hand in!
What's the worst that could happen?
We've already stuck our hands in so many things!
Guys!
Surely this won't be no different!
I ain't scared.
Our hands have been through so much together.
Alright, what's this?
It's a needle.
Oh, it's the second hand!
Cool.
Oh.
Not cool.
Alright, hello?
Hello?
Moshi moshi?
Wait, I heard something back here.
Hello?
Who's that?
Is that the seductress again?
Begone, seductress.
Hmm, where are you?
I heard something.
I know I heard something.
Wait, what happened?
Pyramid Head was here.
He was here!
Wait, he was here and he closed the door!
Cause he was like, you're letting the hot air come out.
That's him!
He was here!
And he didn't even say hi!
What the fuck does Scott even mean at this point?
I don't fucking... what?
What the fuck does Scott mean?
Like...
How?
I did it.
I don't know.
I don't know what that means.
What does Scott equals 3?
How?
How does Scott equals 3?
What does Scott even mean?
How?
Oh my god.
You know, Scott, you know?
You know, the silly guy?
Was there any hint to tell me what the fuck Scott meant?
There's the double doors I can go through?
Which one?
There's so many doors.
I can't remember.
Guys, I don't know where the double doors are.
He's just 3.
Oh my god.
Where do I go?
Below the current floor?
I can go below?
The fuck?
Why did I get to this part of the map?
Okay.
Oh, I have to go downstairs.
We go downstairs.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Guys, I think like...
I don't think I can play more than 2 hours for salad.
Like mentally, I don't know.
Mentally wise, I don't know.
This game is actually...
Oh my god.
I just...
Oh my god, this fucking game.
Oh my god.
Bro, this game is so fucking freaky.
Wait, when the fuck?
When was he there?
I don't remember you being there.
Huh?
Is this a memory from the OG game?
We've only been playing the game for 30...
Guys, this feels like 7 hours of gameplay right now.
You guys might think it's been 30 minutes.
But for me, it was a lifetime.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, we're...
S on the door?
How do I get there?
How the fuck do I get to the S on the door?
Oh, I remember now.
Okay.
Oh, I hate this.
Okay, here we go.
Oh my god, okay, here we go.
Oh hey, it's unlocked.
Is it actually?
What a nice guy, he unlocked it for me.
What a nice guy.
Such a nice boy.
Asa, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
I can't believe you unlocked it for me.
What a great guy.
Such a great guy.
What a bro.
Hey there.
Hey.
Oh man, bro, you work out, bro?
Look at those arms, man.
You work out?
Hello?
Friendly?
Guys.
Guys!
He does not seem very friendly, guys.
Oh no.
Guys.
I'm sorry.
He has thousands of HP?!
Oh my god, my ammo.
What is he gonna do, chase me?
Loop the loop, loop the loop.
Loop him around.
He can't catch me.
I'm sorry!
I'm so sorry!
I didn't mean to piss you off!
He can't catch me.
I thought it was over.
Oh man, that's gonna be a shame.
Oh no.
We got this, guys.
We got this, though.
We got this.
Hug the wall.
No, god!
Okay, I'm sorry!
I am so very sorry.
I... whoa, okay.
Okay.
We have this now.
He can't destroy all of them!
Right?
Okay, guys, I think he can.
Guys, okay, this is our last one.
Guys.
Guys!
Apparently he can, guys!
Whoa!
I'm dead.
My very first death!
Are you serious?!
I die.
Oh my god!
Like, that's so bullshit!
Guys, that's okay.
Guys, it's okay.
I still...
Guys, I...
Oh my god, why is he so mean?
Guys, it's all part of the plan now.
Guys, it was all part of the plan, guys.
Because now, now I get to keep the bullets I lost.
Wait, I got an idea.
Wait, what?
Why did you do that?
Bro, what?
I just...
I didn't even do anything to you, bro!
I just said, bro, do you work out?
Man, like...
I'm sorry, bro!
I just wanted to ask if you worked out.
Like...
Oh my god.
Is there a problem at home?
Is your wife also dead?
Oh, I know how that feels.
But see, I use my anger in a more therapeutic way.
You see, instead...
I just think about all these...
Whoa, okay.
You know what I do, Pyramid Head?
Instead of being angry, I pretend my dead wife is still alive.
Like...
Some people say that's unhealthy.
Oh.
Oh, I'm so sorry.
Okay, I have an idea.
Oh.
I have an idea.
I...
Oh, he's angry.
He's so angry.
I'm sorry.
Oh my god.
This is as good as I could get.
Oh, he's gonna grab now?
Bro, what?
Okay.
Time to play Dark Souls, guys.
Time to play Dark Souls.
That's my idea.
Okay.
It's Dark Souls time.
Oh my god, I thought it was...
I thought it was over.
Oh my god, Wukong prepared me for this.
Wukong prepared me for this.
Oh my god, this is a Souls game.
How much more is he gonna swing?
Swing!
Okay.
Please, sir.
Have you ever tried fucking chopping the other sexy monsters?
It's not as fun as chopping me.
I don't have to build like those other monsters.
Oh god.
Oh my god.
Until he dies?
Oh, he's...
Hello?
Oh.
Hello.
Is he...
Oh, the siren!
What if I...
I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry.
I don't know.
I thought he'd let me in.
I thought he'd be too busy.
He's like, you know what?
I'll give him that one.
I was like...
I thought he'd be like, you know what?
Here, you deserve this one hit.
You deserve it.
I don't know.
I thought he'd give me that one.
I thought he'd be chill like that.
I don't know.
I legitimately thought he'd be chill like that.
Don't interrupt the man on his way to bingo.
Guys, he was not chill.
Guys, he was absolutely not chill like that.
I thought...
I was like, oh shit, man.
A freebie?
Do I get a freebie?
I didn't.
In the end, Yoki did not get a freebie.
He was not chill.
Guys, he was not chill.
Why did nobody warn me that he wasn't chill?
I thought he was chill.
Okay, nice ammo.
Welp, that was two fucking health kits gone.
Whoops.
That was like a little oopsie.
I could've stockpiled more heals.
He gave us no...
You knew I was gonna poke him.
He was standing right there.
You knew I wanted to.
Oh, Mr. Save?
Little girl.
Don't think I forgot what a little fucking brat you are.
What does she see in Silent Hill?
What's like the scariest things for her?
That's not very nice.
Didn't your parents teach you any manners?
What you got there?
It's normal.
She sees a nice city.
Oh my god, you're right.
She has it.
You didn't love Mary any...
Oh wait, is she reading my letter?
How do you know her name?
Yeah, how does she know?
Who are you?
She's not real.
I knew children weren't real.
I fucking knew kids weren't real.
We all came out as adults.
Wait, there's a save point?
Where's the save point?
Where is it?
Children were...
Oh, there it is.
Children were invented by the government.
To make us docile and weak.
I fucking knew it.
We were all born in those pods.
We were all pod people.
Born in a fucking chamber.
And then let out when we go to college.
We were all test tube adults.
I knew they weren't real.
Just like...
I knew it.
I knew they were built and not born.
Oh, we're in the garden now.
Where am I?
Rosewater Park.
That doesn't sound too bad.
Park doesn't sound bad.
It sounds pretty nice.
Man, I wish I had that city mod right now where it looks like a beautiful city.
I...
Imagine if I had that mod that makes everything like actually a city and removes all the fucking fog.
That'd be a nice experience right about now.
Oh, hey, more ammo.
What do you mean, Doki?
I do see a beautiful city.
What are you talking about?
Don't do this to me.
Mary, could you...
Patrick, Chester, son of Edward, he fought and...
Studied for the people.
Yes, you think he studied for the people?
For liberty and for all of our tomorrows.
His memory lives on.
There's more loot.
Yes, studied.
What else could it possibly say?
Like, I don't know where I'm supposed to actually go.
I'm just hoping I grab loot before, like, the actual place.
In memory of the 67 who died of illness and now sleep beneath the lake.
The fuck happened in the lake?
If I go forward, does this progress the game?
If I go through the... the...
What's that word called?
That thing?
Is this Alan Wake in the lake?
If I go through this, does it progress?
Yeah, the pier.
The pier.
Oh, okay.
Okay, so I'll just... I wanna make sure I got all the loot first.
Loot time.
What?
How's the gate closed?
There's nothing locking it.
Okay.
Go this way.
Guy wearing a big metal pyramid and wielding a knife that is big as clouds.
Yeah, he's... I don't know!
He could be a cosplayer!
Guys, you can't judge a person's cosplay.
New fear unlocked.
Is he a cosplayer or a murderer?
Or both?
Oh, hey.
Quite a little... Oh, it's just like... It's... Oh, wait.
It talks about Silent Hill.
Fill your heart with peace.
Remorse during your time here will be pleasant and leave you with memories.
Oh yeah, definitely lots of memories.
He never... Okay, look.
Like, then... Then I... You know, I figured, like, he fixed his issues.
He got less angry.
On the statue?
Which one?
There was, like, 200 million statues.
What the fuck?
Influx, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Hey Doki, if I can play, like, a dragon guy first, so can you.
I don't know who... I didn't know anyone going in, but I still got a lot of the story beat.
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Is that the statue?
I'm open to explore it if it's, like, not a super long game.
But I also have, like, a million other games we need to finish.
The one that looks like a statue?
Okay, well, we're not getting it.
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Uh...
Let's see...
Okay, how important is the loot?
How important is the loot, guys?
Is it the statue?
That's just a fucking statue!
There's... Oh my God, guys, you gotta be...
You gotta be very specific on which statue it is.
Because... Because I'm lost.
Which one?
They're missing heads!
There's more than one statue?
This one?
It's the guy that said he studied!
He studied for the people!
Oh my God.
The other one.
Jesus Christ.
Which... There's so many.
Guys, I think I explored everything around.
They all have no head!
Guys, where?
Where?
I ran!
How?
How did I run past a fucking statue?
Oh my God.
The headless one between the other headless one and the headless... Oh my fucking God.
Oh my God, how many statues are there?
I don't even... I don't even think there were that many statues!
Oh my God, what do you mean I'm blind?
I don't understand.
That's just lore.
That's just lore!
What do you mean it's...
Where have I been?
Okay, I grabbed it there.
That's where I came in.
Oh my God, whoever's waiting for me at that fucking pier, I'm sorry.
Whoever's still waiting for me at the... I think I got one guy.
I think... There's no way.
There's no... I literally ran around this area like 200...
I got one guy.
There's no way.
There was no... There's no statue.
There's no fucking statue, was there?
There was no loot, was there?
It was just... Read this.
There's no way.
I must have got one guy.
I literally... I do not see what you see.
I... I do not see... You passed it?!
Where?!
Oh my God, I swear to God.
I'm fucking... I'm walking now.
I'm shimmying.
I'm fucking walking now.
I'm fucking... I'm like literally walking slow.
Guys, you're wasting your own time.
I told you.
I can only handle two hours of Silent Hill.
This counts in the two hours.
Guys, I need you guys to know.
These are the actions of your mistakes, guys.
This counts in your two hours.
I need you... I need you to know that.
You... you have to remember that this fucking counts.
So you guys better... better... you guys can continue to fuck with me.
You guys can continue to fuck with me.
Look up.
What do you mean look up?!
Now fucking do it again.
Bro, I'm fucking... I'm pressing E.
I'm literally... I'm literally spamming E at everything.
You guys are fucking with me.
There's no way.
There's... there's no... Along the fence?!
This?!
There's no fucking way.
There's no fucking way there was anything here.
I refuse to believe.
There's no fucking way.
There's actually no fucking way.
I am not stalling!
You guys keep telling me I missed the loot!
Oh my god.
That's it.
I'm turning the car around.
I'm... just remember this... this counts.
This counts in your... in your slotted two hours.
This fucking...
This... remember what they took from you because I...
They took this... remember what they took from you.
Some of us are innocent.
No, you didn't stop the... you didn't stop the guilty one.
If they were innocent, you would have stopped them.
Now, you all get punished together.
Wait, she's not?
She's Maria, but what if she was bad?
Woah!
This body is reserved for my fucking dead wife.
No touchy.
Yeah, it's been a very long three years, man.
She can't... she can't be dead.
I stopped taking my meds.
I can still hear her.
Our special place?
Is this our special place?
Our only special place?
I, uh... I don't know anymore.
There was... something.
I just... I can't quite...
Hey!
Like I don't know.
I mean, there's this one place.
Not far from here.
What kind of place?
The kind two lovers might call special.
Wait, it's her special place?
Unless you have somewhere else to be.
Woah!
Be gone, woman!
You seductress!
I'm just messing with you.
This body is for God and my dead wife.
It's this way.
Then she tried to touch me.
I gotta go to HR now.
Be gone, temptress.
I've been... he's been holding it in for three years.
One touch is gonna set him off.
I'm sorry.
Um, past tense?
I love her.
She's alive, goddammit.
How dare you give me the past tense of love?
She's still there.
My dead wife is alive.
What is this BGM?
This is such a fucking weird BGM.
Like, I'm like, what is this BGM that we're listening to?
What the fuck?
Did she just shake her?
Woah!
Maria, I'm sorry.
Maria, I'm sorry, Maria.
But like, I'm sorry, Maria.
But like, I'm sorry.
But like...
Woah!
Woah, give me a sec.
Let me calm down.
Gotta get some composure.
Gotta look in the sky and think of God.
If I look in the sky, I won't be tempted.
Don't tempt me.
Can I just shoot her?
No, I can't.
Okay.
Doc, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Just asked her to dress up like your dead wife.
Problem solved.
Not fucking weird at all.
What does she see?
Wait, she's in my mind, so she doesn't see shit.
Right?
Okay.
Yeah, this was locked before.
Did she die?
Guys?
Okay, before we move on, can she die?
I need to know.
Yes?
Oh God, okay.
Okay.
It's an escort mission.
Okay, here we go.
It's time.
Oh no, it's fucking time.
Okay, it's time.
It's time.
Oh my God.
It's...
Oh hey.
So far from home.
Alright, now we know.
Now we know that we gotta escort her.
Oh, nice.
Bullets.
I love me some bullets.
We're gonna be using a lot of that.
Okay, I'm gonna make sure I got all the loot.
I assume we have to go up from here, right?
Alright,
oh my God.
Oh my God, why?
Why?
Why did they give me an escort mission?
I'm already going through so much.
I'm...
Oh my God.
The spirit is loyal but the flesh...
Oh no.
I thought... me loves she.
Why do I have to do this again?
The worst part is I can't make her just be like, sit.
Just stay.
Stay.
Don't do anything.
Can I go to the ladies room?
Oh hey, nice.
Alright.
Okay, nice.
I got some meds.
Oh my God.
Okay, here we go.
Here we go.
We're off.
Come on, Ashley.
I mean, hot Maria.
Hotter Maria.
Maria, if she let me...
Maria, if she, you know, does what I want for my birthday.
If she lets me actually pick my birthday present.
I know.
Okay.
Let's see.
Alright.
Where do we go?
Do we go to Jack's Inn?
You know what would have been better?
If she puts on the... if she puts on the hat.
Maria, why won't you put on the dog hat?
I thought we were both gonna get freaky.
Alright.
Everything would have been perfect if she also puts on the hat.
It's like you froze for a second.
Where the fuck do I go?
I guess I go up here?
Almost perfect.
Oh, I can.
I was gonna say.
I wonder if I can break into the ones that are... Oh, nice.
The ones that don't have the red card.
Oh my God, look at all these meds.
Look at all... Oh.
See, it's... Guys, guys.
I'm not cheating on my dead wife, guys.
It's two separate beds.
It's... I would never do that to her.
It's two separate beds, guys.
There's two beds.
How dare you say that?
I am loyal.
I'm so goddamn loyal.
Oh, wait.
Let me see this.
I'm fixing the pipes at 107.
Okay.
Oh, there's a pin.
Okay, we gotta figure out the pin for this.
We could figure out the pin for this, or...
Or...
Guys.
iPad, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, thank you.
Oh, shit!
Okay!
Okay.
Oh, shit.
Okay, we're fine.
No shot.
iPad, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Don't let that Harlan Murray distract you.
Mary's phone is all the material you need.
Jesus.
I can't!
Guys!
We can't!
We can't just only look at her photo!
What?
There's nothing here.
I see nothing.
Wow, what a lucky guess, guys.
So lucky.
Nice meds.
What's that?
What's going on out there?
Wait, did I use up all- Oh, I was gonna say, like, what?
What's this?
1, 1 less, 3, 1 more, 8, 3 less, 0, 1 more.
Oh, this was- This was 0, 4, 5, 1.
I'm so fucking smart.
Look at that.
Oh, shit.
What the fuck?
That's a- That's dead woman's clothes.
I mean, I'm used to that, but like-
She gonna put it on?
What's she gonna do with it?
Is she just gonna look at it?
We have places to be.
Oh, is that the OG outfit?
Wait, that is?
Oh, the door- You can open the door.
Wait, I wanna see it again.
Wait, which one- Oh, that one?
That was the OG outfit?
H-O-T-T-O-G-O.
Oh, that's cute.
Oh, that's a cute easter egg.
Alright.
Save.
Guys, I know we have the photo of Mary, but like- Guys, please, it's been three- Guys, please, it's been three years.
How much longer must I wait?
Okay.
Okay, what the fuck do I- What do I do with this key?
What do I do with this key?
I don't even remember what key I got.
Uh, equipment.
Is it here?
No.
No, this hardly belongs to the streets.
Oh, the gate key.
It's like right here.
If you let Maria die, she'll have more income.
Guys, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Papa Samir, thank you for the super chat.
Is it down this way?
Which way?
You can't just say- There's two ways.
There's two ways.
Okay, assume it's this way.
Okay, Maria.
Now that we're in an intersection, which one is down?
Where are you trying to take me?
Left or right, Maria?
You can't say it's down this way and then we're in a fucking- Do we have a left or right?
Like,
where do you wanna go?
I'm just gonna go this way just to see if there's like- Okay, okay.
Oh, you know what?
You could've told me it's not this way.
You could've fucking told me.
Yeah, you could've told me it's a dead end.
Please.
Please don't remind me.
Aww.
That's so sweet.
Wow!
You harlot.
You fucking harlot.
I knew it.
Hellfire.
Why are you getting close?
Don't touch me.
Oh my god, not in front of my dead wife.
That witch.
I fucking knew it.
You can't trust no woman.
It's a witch.
We gotta set her on fire.
Oh my god.
I can't believe it.
I am strong.
My will is strong.
I'll never betray her.
But like, okay, but she is here.
She is here and my dead wife is not here.
So, oh my gosh.
Guys, the longer we're here together, the harder this is gonna make it.
Let's see.
Be strong.
What?
The fucking empty cat?
Whoa, the plot holes got crazy in Silent Hill.
Come on.
Are you serious?
Are you- Aww, and I have to kill all of them because I need to- Oh no, I don't.
Just go.
Leave.
They can't- What are they gonna do?
Open the gates?
They don't have thumbs.
Wait, that's my stick.
That's my hurdy stick.
Oh, I don't need a hurdy stick no more.
I got the hurdy pole.
It's upgraded.
Oh shit!
That was a bad idea.
What the fuck are you- I said stay close, not go towards the bombing.
That is the opposite of close.
Where am I supposed to go?
Oh god.
Okay, this is not good.
What is this?
Alright, this is not good.
They have high heals now.
This is not good.
They have high heals, guys.
It's not looking so good.
They're wearing heals.
Oh no.
Oh no, it's getting worse.
It's getting worse!
They're wearing heals now!
Now it's gonna accentuate their legs!
No!
Now they look even better.
Oh no, they're hotter now.
What the fuck?
Okay, goodbye.
Goodbye.
Yeah, it's bad because- Oh my god, it makes their legs look so cool.
What the fuck?
What?
Why?
Why are you still there?
Okay.
Wait, ammo was missed?
Where?
Sorry, I had to go back.
And I missed some ammo.
Not there.
Oh, there!
Nice, alright.
Sorry, man.
This was very, very important.
One guy was just walking around.
Just vibing.
You know what?
I feel- Oh my god, wait, she's wearing a thong!
Wait, he's wearing a thong!
Wait, no!
No, it's just their skin.
Okay.
God, I'm a fucking mess.
I'm a little bit freaky right now.
What's over there on the side?
Oh, he doesn't know.
That's right.
You know what?
Fuck it.
I figured I have enough ammo for it.
I have enough.
That's fucking right.
Yeah, that's right.
Yeah!
Get predicted!
I know your patterns now!
Wait, I actually know all their patterns.
Wait, this is easy.
What's that sound?
Oh god!
Oh, that's- You fucking gamers don't look down!
I look down!
Okay.
I'm like confused on- Wait, what the fuck?
Get out!
Oh, shit!
Oh!
Oh my god!
I didn't realize they still existed.
I thought they were gone!
Okay, that was my bad.
I legitimately forgot these things existed in the world.
I was like, you're not indoors?
What are you doing here?
You're supposed to be an indoor monster!
Like how cats are supposed to be indoors!
Okay.
What the fuck are you doing?
My bad.
That's my bad.
Alright.
Are you ready?
Are we here?
Wait, there's more?
Oh my god, that's a dead end?
What's the point?
Oh, here.
Okay, I was like, what the fuck was the point?
Is there any sneaky guy?
Anybody trying to sneak around?
Where did she go?
I think Maria said over there.
Wait, where are you going?
Maria, you are not supposed to run off on fire.
You are not- Oh my god, Maria, please.
Wait, where did she go?
Maria, please!
This is your fault!
Maria!
Please!
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
Maria, this is silly!
Please!
Where did she go?
I'm so fucking mad now.
Maria, you fucking bitch!
You made me- Oh my god, I was trying to- Maria, why is she there?
I wasted so many heals.
Oh my god, why is she- But she aggroed everybody too!
You're such a bitch!
I can say that.
I can say that because she was.
She did not have to do that.
She did not have to fucking do that.
I'm so mad.
She actually aggroed everybody over.
We could've just walked over.
Oh my god.
I freaked out because I was like, am I supposed to protect her?
And then they all turned around for me!
If I could kick you out of the party, I would.
You weren't so hot right now.
Oh my god, of course.
Guess where this key was.
Oh, she knows.
You know what?
All is forgiven.
I don't know why, but I just somehow felt like I should forgive you right now.
There's just something about you that made me so forgiving.
That easy?
James has been like...
It's been three years.
Cut James some slack, guys.
It's been three years for this poor man.
I like how there's red solo cups.
Oh, ammo.
Nice.
Oh, thank god there's ammo.
Where'd you go?
Maria?
Where did you go?
Hello?
Where'd you go?
Wait, what?
What the fuck?
What was that?
I missed a picture?
Okay.
There's a lot of stuff I missed.
Ammo, nice.
There was a mirror?
Oh, there was.
Oh, there it is.
Oh my god, is she gonna...
Ready to kill it.
Oh my god.
No, it is.
It's a strip club.
It's Heaven's Next.
Wait, is it Heaven's Exit or Heaven's Night?
Alright, let's go.
Alright.
It's time to fuck y'all.
There's the private rooms.
Alright.
Maria, I'm sorry.
Maria, just...
Maria, just remember...
Maria, three years.
I made it past three years, Maria.
I just need you to know that.
I made it three years, Maria.
I've tried so hard.
Stay strong.
Maria, please, you can't...
You can't be mad at me, Maria.
Maria, please, she's just like you.
What?
It's almost November, guys.
It's not November yet!
Fucking shut up.
There's dead monsters outside!
Mary could be out there.
My dead wife could be out there right now, walking around, very much alive.
No, it's my fault.
No, you're right.
It is my fault.
That time when you aggroed them, I'm still feeling that pain.
I guess this place is getting to me, too.
Am I crazy?
James, you should have asked that a long time ago.
I can think of another.
What's that?
Possibly... There's no... There's no, James.
No, you're perfectly normal.
Oh no, he's becoming self-aware, chat.
Oh, hey.
You're right.
If I drink more alcohol, I won't see them as... Oh, I'll see them as even hotter.
Cheers!
Beer o'clock!
Guys, I'm getting tempted.
What do I do?
And it's working.
What do I do, guys?
Guys, I don't know how much longer I can stay strong, guys.
Did I not drink it?
Wait, did I not drink it?
What the fuck happened in that cutscene?
Lost and found.
What the fuck happened in there?
See, look, guys.
I didn't... I'm stronger than she thinks.
Guys, look at that.
I'll never betray her.
See, guys?
I didn't... I didn't fuck up.
Whoa.
I mean... Yeah?
You like that, guys?
Magic Mike right now?
What's your wife going to do?
Haunt you?
I think... I think she's doing that right now.
Alright, we gotta go follow her?
Wait, what?
This is like a safe place?
Am I missing anything in my safe spot?
Wait, that's where the...
Oh, there it is.
That's... Yeah, there it is.
I was like, where the fuck is the save?
Okay.
Oh.
Anything... Oh!
Oh my god, they're showing all the parts.
My god, where are you?
Oh my gosh.
Okay, I'm ready.
I'm ready.
I'm strong.
Come on.
Don't be tempted.
I'm strong.
In the booth?
There's a booth?
There's a booth seat?
Remember when I said I was ready?
Sorry, I gotta look for items.
Oh, there it is!
Oh my god.
Is this what you wanted me to see, guys?
Are you satisfied?
Guys, please.
I'm strong.
I am strong.
Oh my god.
Somebody left their shoes.
I can come back to it.
Put it on.
There's a bar item?
There is?
Guys, guys, remember, this counts in your two hours, guys.
Guys, remember, this counts in the two hour limit.
Alright, back at it again.
Back at it again.
Yo, it's that statue item from before!
There we are, it goes in.
Oh, it's the hospital, isn't it?
I see the hospital.
Oh, I see the hospital.
I see it, guys.
I see it.
Oh, if it's not through here, where is it through?
Oh, I have to go through this way.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Look, I am desperate for ammo, ma'am.
Who's gonna care?
These cars are abandoned!
I wanna make sure all the cars are fucked up.
Okay, nothing.
Okay.
Wait, where does this go?
Alright, we'll see now.
Okay, nothing.
Oh my god.
Guys, I'm so bad with maps, guys.
Is it obvious that I'm bad at reading maps?
Does it seem that obvious, guys?
What?
Where?
You mean this fucking bug?
Okay.
Where the fuck do I go?
The fuck?
Oh, here.
No.
Oh my god.
Maria, where?
Where?
Maria, please.
Where do I go?
I'm so fucking... I'm so confused.
Here?
Maria, please!
You know where to go!
The garden?
Oh my god, it was the fucking garden.
Look, Maria said she knows where it is, but she has not been leading me anywhere.
That's all I'm saying.
I've been trying to figure this out on my own.
Sorry, Maria, can you please tell me where?
Maria, please, I would really like to know where the garden is.
If you could please tell me where it is.
Oh my god, I'm just walking.
Oh, is that Eve?
A story told around these parts.
Kind of a local legend.
Tells of a woman who was cast out.
Sentenced to die on an island out on the lake.
There was a man in town who fell madly in love with her.
Every night, he would sneak out.
Row across the lake, bringing her food and company.
That's nice.
That's romantic.
Every night, he would stand there on the shore, holding a lit candle to help him find his way.
But this one night, a terrible storm...
Why don't they just leave?
Caught him out in the open, and it blew out the candle.
No!
So he couldn't...
Even in darkness, the man would not give up.
He, like, got lost.
And the moon turned back.
So he fought against the raging waters until finally the lake took him.
But that's just a local legend.
It's not true, right?
The woman never lost hope.
She kept coming out at night.
Kept lighting the candle.
To bring her beloved home.
Okay, at that point, you know he's dead.
Not sure how much truth there is to it.
It's probably just a fairy tale.
Some say he's still rowing to this very day.
But she's become something of a local saint.
Patron of undying love.
Hence this place.
She's not here.
What?
Oh, now she realized he was delusional.
This was a mistake.
I shouldn't have come here.
Oh, whoa!
Oh my god, she knows.
She knows I'm vulnerable right now.
There's plenty of other places to look.
You witch.
Whoa.
She knows.
She knows I'm vulnerable right now.
I'm trying to find my special place.
Don't let your guard down, Doki.
Doki.
Doki, no!
You're letting your guard down!
Oh shit, am I supposed to go up here?
Just break up- break all the glasses.
Glasses.
She only likes me because of my mask.
Oh shit.
Oh thank god, escort mission over.
Wait, Eddie?
Wait, they're alive!
Wait, they're both alive!
They're alive.
Okay, I just wanted to be sure.
Hello?
Hey guys!
What movie are you guys watching?
Wait, in Silent Hill, do the movies change as well?
The fuck happened to- oh, it's ice cream.
Oh, are you eating your feelings out, bro?
You okay?
How have you forgotten about me?
Oh my god, James.
James, you- Eddie, you okay, buddy?
I don't think she's okay.
Hey,
ice cream can ex- ice cream can expire.
Wait, the freezer still works here?
Oh, and he wipes it off his shirt!
That's how you get ants!
The freezer works in Silent Hill.
Why'd you look for the little girl?
Oh...
Oh, damn.
Damn, that's karma, James.
You let a woman follow you, but not Eddie.
Bro, what happened, man?
He seems like a bro, bro.
Is she up there?
Oh...
Oh, I don't like this.
Back at it again, but we're in a movie theater.
Okay, alright, up we go.
Up we go.
Hello?
Little girl?
Are you here, little girl?
I don't think she's here, guys.
Oh my god, that's an old projector.
Little girl?
What the fu- I'm angry!
Where do I go?
I'm angry, but I don't know where to go.
Oh, there.
I'm angry and lost!
Oh, there she is.
Why the fuck are you running away?
Like, you were okay hanging out with Eddie, and I look much more approachable than Eddie.
Like, I'm not eating my feelings out right now.
Not today.
I did yesterday, but not today!
Okay.
A stranger?
Oh, and Eddie's no less- not much less of a stranger than I am?
Alright.
If anything, Eddie is even more of a fucking- oh, that's it, there's- oh my god, that's so- That makes me uncomfortable.
That's where he was.
What?
Did she go outside?
I'm gonna use the bathroom here.
She went outside?
Okay, that's enough time for me to explore.
Molly, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Okay, maybe there's more stuff here.
Look, we gotta loot, okay guys?
This is important.
We can go after Laura whenever the- look, she ran out on her own free will.
Okay, nice, more bullets.
She's the one that decided to run out, guys.
I'm not her guardian.
If anything, it's even more dangerous for me to approach her because I am a stranger.
If anything, Maria should be the one to approach her, not me.
People are gonna be like, what the fuck are you trying to chase after this little girl?
I'm just trying to make sure that...
I'm doing the right thing.
It doesn't help that I'm wearing a dog mask too, so that does not help my case.
But wearing this dog mask is a fucking choice.
You see the little- that's like the fucking weirdest thing to ask somebody.
Oh no, why are you at the hospital?
Oh no, it's the goddamn- Oh no, it's the hospital, no.
No, not the fucking- Leave, please do not stay with me if you're coming with me to the hospital.
Please, there's hot nurses and I don't know what to do.
Please, I cannot protect you no more.
I'm gonna let the beasts unleash here in the hospital.
Alright, let's- Okay, here we go.
Alright, let's see if there's...
The crow- oh no, there's a shotgun here.
Okay.
Your weapon pointed- okay, there's apparently a shotgun here.
And where the fuck is the shotgun?
Oh my god, okay, we're not in the other world yet, so that's good.
Wait, is there a map in there?
Where- where's the map?
Where is the map?
I don't know which way to go.
Go to the right?
Oh wait, is that the map?
Oh, there it is.
Alright.
That's a lot of rooms.
Oh my god, we're not at the other world yet though, so...
Maybe things will not be as bad.
Oh shit, is this depression?
Oh shit.
Okay, that's not good.
Laura, there you are.
It's okay, we don't want to hurt you.
Oh, she was the one that's drawing this.
Why is she running from- I don't know, James!
I don't know.
Strangers are always not a great- James, I don't know.
You don't even know this little girl, and you- I don't know, James.
Do you even know Laura?
Do you even know her?
Why is she running from me?
Alright.
The director requested the files of the three crucial patients.
You know which one.
Can you please bring them to the office?
Oh no.
Oh shit, thank god there's a save.
Oh my god, thank god.
Wait,
did I already miss it?
Alright.
Did I already find the- Did I already find the note or nah?
Oh, you guys fuckers.
You fuckers.
You think I don't remember your name, fucking Solid Snake?
Oh, I'm gonna- Alright, the moment this turns to the other world is over.
The moment we see the nurse, I'm fucking out of here.
Alright.
We go up.
Alright, up we go.
Oh wait, how do we go down?
What's downstairs?
Okay, it's still locked.
Oh my god, we're gonna be in the hospital for- Oh no.
I can tell we're gonna be in the hospital for a while.
Why are there so many doors and keys?
Okay.
Wait, what?
I can't even go through this door.
What?
That door doesn't work.
Am I missing something?
Oh shit!
Okay.
Alright, here we go.
Elevator?
Oh, apparently I don't have fucking fingers no more.
This has to be close to the other world now.
Wait, what?
What is keeping me out?
I see window.
I break!
There's no laws here.
Except for that door.
Oh, there it is.
I wrote down for you what you should remember.
Once you're in the lobby, just look around.
Now remember, nurses- Oh my- Nurses, doctors, trees.
Okay.
Okay, a riddle.
Alright, we gotta count the nurses, doctors, and trees.
I can break the cabinets?
What?
What cabinets?
Alright.
Which one?
Four cabinets?
Oh, this one!
Oh my god, I didn't even see that.
I knew I could break it, but I wasn't paying attention.
Okay.
You guys all know that.
Okay, nurses, doctors, trees.
What's- Guys, I know what tree is, but where's the tree at?
Okay, oh, there you go.
Four.
Alright, two, four.
Two, four, six, seven.
Seven, two, four.
Alright.
I'm smart.
Seven, two, four.
There you go.
Oh, we did it.
We did it.
We got the basement.
Basement.
Of course.
Okay.
It was actually- Oh, wait, I had to un- I must have had to grab the note.
I must have had to grab the note to get seven, two, four.
This place feels so empty.
Oh my god.
Look at the basement.
Okay, I got this.
At least they're hot.
Just remember, Doki.
They might not have faces and they might want to try and kill you.
But, hey.
You die doing what you love.
Okay.
It's been three years.
This?
No, okay.
Okay.
Hello, nurse.
Hello, nurse?
What?
It is?
Why is she still following me?
I agree.
By the way, I have 58 bullets.
Do you think that's enough?
Sorry.
61 now.
No.
No, okay.
Guess I gotta hoard them more.
Oh god, I need...
Like, I need...
Oil?
Gas?
Thank you for the superchat.
Thank you.
What?
Bro, what the...
Okay, that...
I was promised nurses.
What the...
Oh, I'm sorry.
You don't...
You just legs.
Where?
Oh my god, I was promised nurses.
This is not what I signed up for.
This was not what I signed up for.
Hahaha.
I didn't realize there were other monsters here.
I was fucking promised a nurse.
But they're not nurses?
Bro, what?
Did they like come from...
I swear.
I swear, they...
They jump from a...
Do they jump from above?
I just didn't see.
I must have not just saw.
I just must have not seen it.
Did they jump from above?
Gamers don't know.
Of course I don't look up.
Holy shit, that scared the shit out of me.
Bro, now they're gonna be up?
That's cheating!
That's actually cheating.
Holy shit.
That...
Where?
Actually, where?
Holy cow.
I swear.
What?
I looked.
I even looked.
I even like made sure to look.
Oh my god, these fuckers.
Please don't kill me this time.
You're not...
You're not gonna fool me this time.
That's right.
Okay, I'm okay.
Literally in my walls right now.
I don't get anything from it.
I...
Where did you come from?
I barely heard
you.
What the fuck?
Where did that guy come from?
Hey, just got the map.
Let's go.
Oh my god.
That was actually bullshit.
Oh, it just wanted to leave.
Bro, that one was actually bullshit.
Holy shit.
Oh my god.
Oh, it's empty?
There's a cart I could push?
Where?
Bye.
Okay.
It's E, right?
No, I couldn't get there.
Yeah, it did a full circle.
So I'm like trying to figure out where the fucking oil is.
Or gas.
I went to the storage yet?
I did, right?
Yeah, I went to pick that up.
I saw a hole in the...
Oh, okay.
I don't remember.
Guys, I don't know if you know this, but I don't remember where things are.
How do we push this?
It has to be in this room.
But like, where's the...
Oh, there it is.
Okay.
There it is.
There's the cart.
We fucking did it, boys.
Mario, you wanna fucking give me space here?
Does it fit in the square hole?
It does.
Let's go.
Okay.
I still wanna know where the fuck that guy came from.
That's the guy that just...
Like...
Like, where did he come from?
That was crazy.
I fill up the gas.
Gas, gas, gas.
And then he was like, you're gonna open the door?
Let me...
He's just like, why did you hit me?
I just wanna go through the door.
Bro, that guy fucking jumpscared me.
Of course I was gonna slap him.
Oh.
Back around.
We're doing a little Mario go round.
Back at it again.
It was this way.
Oh my god.
I put the generator on.
Okay.
On.
Oh nice.
There's light.
Thank god there's light.
Oh thank god.
We can use the elevator.
Nice, there's one...
Oh my god, okay.
I don't know what his plans were.
Like, I...
What was your plan?
I... okay.
I...
I don't know what he was trying to do.
I don't know.
What the fuck was that?
His best, okay.
Wait, is it gonna open?
Oh, okay.
Alright.
Oh.
Wait a minute.
I'm in the other world.
We're here.
Wait a minute.
I turned on the lights.
How did it get darker?
How the fuck did it get darker?
Alright guys, we're calling it here.
It got darker.
It was either other world or darkness.
It was other world or dark...
And we made it to the other world.
We're stopping here.
We're stopping here guys.
It was one or the other.
And that part was...
We'll get nurses on the next playthrough.
Okay guys?
Nurses at the next one.
You get to see...
You get to be more hype for nurses.
There actually is not other world in this one.
Only darkness.
Okay, well it got dark and I'm a pussy.
So I'm a chicken.
So we got it here.
Oh my god.
What a long day today.
Today was a long day.
But I always had so much fun hanging out with you guys, dragons.
It's always great.
I'm glad you guys...
I hope you guys had a good time watching.
Not gonna lie.
Like I said, Silent Hill is...
So fucking scary man.
Silent Hill, I've never...
I'm just...
I'm just scared.
It's just scary.
I think I hate this game as much as you.
Screw this stupid game.
I hate all of this game.
Liam, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Lali, thank you for the super chat.
Like, I just...
I don't know what to say.
Like, it is...
It's just...
It's just fucking...
But yeah, it just freaks me out a lot.
Trying to...
Play Silent Hill because it's just...
The ambience is so good.
The ambience is very good.
And it makes me...
Like, makes me like...
What do I do?
It does what it does really, really well.
In terms of...
The spooky factor of it.
Yeah, it's legendary for a reason.
Yeah.
I'm glad they did a remake of this.
So like, it's more accessible to play.
But oh my god.
My heart though.
Like, I know I like joke around a lot.
But oh my gosh.
I have to joke around.
To like...
To try and play through.
Like, to try and like progress.
Or I'll be like really scared.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Do you think the game being quiet most of the time is what freaks you out the most?
I think that...
And the fact that...
Like I said before.
It's the fact that like...
Monsters don't die, die.
Like, they come back.
So I always have this fear.
Of like...
Oh my god.
When are they gonna come back alive?
Like...
And shit.
Like, it just...
It just freaks me out.
And then they always try to jump scare you too.
Cause they're always lurking.
They're not like...
It's not like...
Like you can...
It's not easy to tell when they show up.
So you're always trying to check your corners and everything.
And that's like...
Really...
It's just really like...
Oh my god.
What do I do?
What do...
No one...
Yeah, exactly.
No one ever dies.
So I'm just like...
Hey, guys.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I don't know what you're talking about.
I'm having a great time watching someone else play.
While I sit in the brightly lit room.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Yeah, I have all my lights turned on right now.
When I play Silent Hill.
It's just...
Like I can't play this game in the dark at all.
But yeah.
I hope you guys had a fun time watching.
And I hope you guys enjoyed...
Hanging out today.
For a full day today.
It's been a great time.
Tomorrow we do have two streams.
One is the Shinova tournament.
It is like knockout stage.
So that means...
That means...
If we don't...
We can basically end the stream after one game.
So we'll see how it goes.
We'll see how it goes.
I know like there's a lot of games.
Like the second...
The tournament stream.
The second day too.
I'm not sponsored for day two.
I'm actually only sponsored for day one.
So I can basically say whatever the fuck I want on day two.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I literally covered half of my screen.
The stream was on towards the end there.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Anyway guys.
To be fair.
I said we...
Me and Surefour.
We're both sponsored on our team.
Said a lot of things on day one.
No, we were already unhinged.
We were...
I don't know how...
How we could get worse.
Cause like we were already very unhinged on day one.
But yeah.
And then after that.
We're gonna do...
Goodnight Dragons.
At nine.
So yeah.
And then Sunday there's no stream obviously.
Cause Sunday's my rest day.
But as always everybody.
Stay hydrated.
Posture.
Get up and move around.
To get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me.
Head to bed.
Cause you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Bye guys.
Bye.